[Music]
the American working class this is a
host of challenges from stagnant family
incomes to dramatic increases in
so-called deaths of despair from drugs
alcohol and suicide but perhaps none is
greater than the decline of the married
two-parent home unlike 50 years ago
Thibault families are longer than normal
working-class America this takes a toll
on working-class kids growing up in a
home without both parents they're more
likely to fail in school and the
pregnant as teens or land in jail it's
also hard for their parents we're more
likely to fall prey to poverty
depression even deaths of despair if
they've been touched by family breakdown
so what to do there are policy steps
like expanding wage subsidies but the
u.s. can take to strengthen the economic
foundations of working-class life but
the most important change just might be
cultural men and women in working-class
America must see that their futures and
the future of their children depend on
renewing stable marriage for themselves
their friends and their communities what
do you think family breakdown has to do
with the state of working-class America
let us know in your comments also let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI